when I left Winterfell I told you we
need allies or we will die but more
importantly we need allies I told you we
needed allies we need allies powerful
allies if we're gonna be allies in this
war it's important for the northerners
to see us as allies if you only trust
the people you grew up with you won't
make many allies that's alright
I don't need many allies I never wanted
a crown I told you I don't want it
doesn't matter what you want I don't
want it I never wanted it I never asked
for it I don't want them to kneel for me
I don't want it
Daenerys is so quick she shouldn't be
you are my queen
I don't know what else I can say you are
my queen while see she is my queen you
will always be my queen you are my queen
you're a man almost I don't have love
here I love you I did this I should go
so definitely murder you stay back he's
got blue eyes I've always had blue eyes
sir we're going to die at Winterfell yes
I think you're right what are you doing
what I think you know I truly don't we
have never had a conversation last this
long without you insulting me not once
you wanted to insult you no good I'm
loyal to the Queen you're loyal to sons
and adult brothers oh [ __ ] loyalty
I don't know how to use it stickin with
the pointy end Sansa thinks she's
smarter than everyone she's the smartest
person I've ever met
you don't want it I don't really want
and you want do you wear the crown why
do you think I came all this way
I saw him riding that thing that's right
you did I did he climbed on the [ __ ]
dragon and fought what kind of person
climbs on a [ __ ] dragon a madman you
can touch me I'm not afraid of violence
maybe you should be the women down here
don't like me the longer I leave my
enemies alone the stronger they become
this is a mistake I mean you look good
once you you fought them did some of
them what do they like bad really bad
really bad men without [ __ ] you
wouldn't find me fighting in an army if
I had no [ __ ] because you have no [ __ ]
even heard you have no [ __ ] at the sort
of thing you start to say once your dick
gets chopped off along with my big [ __ ]
if I lost my [ __ ] I drink all the time
dick talk you can suck his magic cut
later that's like saying I have a bigger
[ __ ] than anyone in the unsullied army
not without the [ __ ] you don't lease
your balls don't freeze off you take
great defensive tortures but love
telling unit jerks why is that because I
have balls new Denver all your
[ __ ] grandsons ruin the family
with their [ __ ] boys I don't
think a [ __ ] is the true qualification
as I'm sure you'd agree [ __ ] are
important I'm afraid maybe Breen is all
[ __ ] in the end so Jamie brake on dick
on
we lost the Greyjoy's left from the
world the last ones with balls anyway
she's coming for you of course she is
what you like down there what that's not
your concern I haven't been with a woman
for years give you a mother here adore
her his eyes where men believe shut your
mouths
he loves our queen and she loves him I
worry about a state of mind
we are advisors to the Queen worrying
about her state of mind is our job
she'll make the right choice with the
help of her loyal advisors with the
right counsel because I think she will
make the world a better place
he said she'd destroyed his landing she
knows herself we still have to take
King's Landing
maybe Circe will win and kill us all
that would solve our problems so what
happens to her please
don't help me
I don't want to see the city burn I
don't want to hear the screams of
children burn him alive no it is not a
pleasant sound i I don't want to hear it
now varus's ashes can tell my ashes see
I told you if not for yourself if not
for her and for every one of the million
people in that city innocent or
otherwise to be honest I never really
cared much for them innocent or
otherwise you know I kill them when I
see one
would you have burned the city down I
don't know
yes you do I know you love her I love
her too
notice successfully as you I stand
before you as one of the senior lords in
the country
a veteran of two wars and I like to
think my experience has led to some
small skill in statecraft I don't
understa please sit the decision about
what's best for everyone and should be
left to o
everyone maybe we should give the dogs
of birds as well my horse and drogon any
word he was last spotted flying east
rather away the better the archmaester
is less than enthusiastic about the
salutary effects of brothels I imagine
he isn't using them properly I think we
can all agree that ships take precedence
over brothels I think that's a very
presumptuous statement I once brought a
jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel